start our four o'clock hour today with
an employment opportunity clark county's
unemployment rate currently sits at just
over 5 percent now commissioners are
hoping to drop that number lower and
connect people with work through a job
fair happening this week they say vegas
is back and it's time to bring our job
force up to speed
if you haven't looked for a job in a
while
you may be surprised with what you'll
find this time around with the cost of
living on the rise
now is the time to find a well-paying
job there is an opportunity for you
the job fair is taking place as the job
market continues to remain competitive
joe moeller is live outside the
convention center with what some
employers are looking for hi joe
hey there vanessa well for over a year
now we've been seeing i've been talking
about the difficulties that these
employers have been having trying to
fill the jobs that they have had many of
them since they reopened during the
pandemic while the convention center
here there will be a job fair happening
on friday hosted by clark county and all
the employers will be offering 18 bucks
an hour for full-time jobs something we
have not seen before at a job fair
we have seen job fairs before but as a
search for employees gets harder and
harder more money is now on the table
all sorts of businesses in a number of
industries have taken interest to the
event maverick helicopters cox cable the
fremont street experience and a number
of strip properties will be there just
to name a few from security to
housekeeping westgate resort has been
trying to add staff ever since they
reopened gordon rudy says it has not
been easy we find that we that we are
offering more money and better
compensation because we have to be
competitive with the other properties
but you know we all want the best people
so we're going to do what we can to get
them new industries are also trying to
fill jobs the cannabis compliance board
will be there as well they tell me they
have about a dozen positions they need
to fill as the state gears up for
cannabis lounges to open this year for
us i think we're just in a really unique
position because as a state agency we
have so many openings
again this all starts here on friday at
9 a.m employers say dress your best and
have your resume handy to pass out on
friday and some employers here will be
hiring on the spot reporting live
outside the convention center joe muller
live local now
for a full list of companies hiring in
the valley just head to eight newsnow
dot com and click the job board tab we
put together a list with links to apply